الجنرال المتقاعد بالجيش الأمريكي ويسلي كلارك هو
محلل عسكري لشبكة CNN والقائد
الأعلى السابق لحلف شمال الأطلسي (الناتو). ينضم إلينا الآن، ومن
دواعي سرورنا أن تكون معنا يا
سيدي، لذلك في أعقاب هذا الهجوم المميت
على القوات الأمريكية في الأردن، تعهد الرئيس جو
بايدن بالانتقام والولايات المتحدة.
يقول وزير الخارجية أنتوني بلينكين
إن الرد سيأتي في المكان
والزمان الذي تختاره أمريكا، واصفًا إياها بأنها
أخطر لحظة منذ أكثر من
50 عامًا. كل هذا معقد بسبب
الحاجة إلى منع هذا الصراع في الشرق الأوسط
من التصعيد بشكل أكبر، كيف يكون
قانون الموازنة الدقيق هذا  تحققت
بهذين الهدفين المتضاربين
وما هو الإجراء الانتقامي المناسب
لمواجهة هذه
اللحظة إنها مشكلة صعبة حقًا
أن الرئيس بايدن يريد أن
يضرب بقوة كافية حتى لا تفعلها إيران
مرة أخرى أه ولكن في نفس الوقت تريد
المحاولة  لعدم منح إيران فرصة لمزيد من
التصعيد وجذب
الولايات المتحدة بشكل أعمق، فهي
مشكلة صعبة وأه أنا متأكد من أن
البيت الأبيض يبحث في ثلاثة
خيارات نظريًا، أحدهما هو خيار ثقيل حقًا،
ثم اختر إيران المجموعة  من
الأهداف الأخرى، وهو خيار أخف، ضرب
أربع أو خمس نقاط مختلفة للميليشيات
وضربها مرارًا وتكرارًا على
مدى يومين أو ثلاثة أيام، وهناك حل وسط
يقول ربما تضرب
بضعة أمطار من
الأصول في الخليج أو ربما إيرانية
سيطرة القائد في العراق في مكان ما أه
لكنك لا تضرب إيران،
ستكون هذه مثل ثلاث
حزم مختلفة سيتم
مناقشتها والنظر فيها من أجل دراسة جدوى
التأثير والعواقب وما إلى ذلك نعم
الرئيس بايدن التقى بأمنه القومي
فريق الاثنين لموازنة هذه
الخيارات الانتقامية المحتملة، كيف
عملوا من خلال هذه الخيارات وما
مدى خطورة ما نواجهه هذه اللحظة في رأيك،
وسيتعين عليهم العمل من خلال
الخيارات من خلال السؤال أولاً عما إذا كانت
مجدية عسكريًا وما هو الحل  المخاطرة
عسكريًا بتنفيذها، هل يمكنك القيام بذلك
بنجاح، وهل ستتكبد
خسائر في القيام بذلك؟ سيكون هذا هو
المعيار الأول ثم
الثاني هو ما هو التأثير الذي
سيكون على إيران ثم
سيكون المعيار الثالث  ما الذي سيحدث وما هو
التأثير في المنطقة
ولذا أه عليهم أن يزنوا كل ما
لديك من اعتبارات دبلوماسية، لديك
اعتبارات عسكرية أه ولذا هناك الكثير
في هذا ولكن أعتقد أن أه هذه هي
اللحظة التي نحن فيها  "سنرى
رد فعل أقوى بكثير منا من رد
الفعل السابق، الآن قد يستغرق الأمر يومًا أو يومين
آخرين، لأننا سنفعل كل ما
سنجمعه معًا
وأعتقد أنه سيكون كذلك"  أكثر من
مجموعة من الضربات وبعض الجمهوريات
تدعو الولايات المتحدة إلى استهداف تان وضربها
بشدة بالانتقام العسكري المدمر،
ماذا تقول
لذلك جيدًا؟ أعتقد أن الجمهوريين
يريدون أن يروا
ضربة قوية لإيران  أه
مراكز قيادة الحرس الثوري الجمهوري أه
في مصانع الشاهد للطائرات بدون طيار في
الرادارات التي سترسل بعد ذلك إشارة
إلى إيران مفادها أنه يمكنك الآن تفجير
راداراتك ولن ترانا قادمين
مرة أخرى وما إلى ذلك، يجب أن تكون هذه الأنواع من الضربات
في  في الحزم التي
يدرسها الرئيس أه لو كنت
جزءًا من سلسلة القيادة تلك،
سأوصي بمجموعة قوية نسبيًا من
الضربات، ما تريد القيام به هو إيقاف هذا
التصعيد الآن والقول لإيران إنه لا يمكنك
تحمل ذلك  تقدم للأمام، لذا قم باستدعاء
الكلاب وما نتعلمه عن هذا
الهجوم المميت هو أن طائرة بدون طيار معادية
دخلت على ما يبدو القاعدة دون أن يتم اكتشافها
مع طائرة بدون طيار أمريكية عائدة، كيف يحدث
ذلك وكيف تمنع حدوث ذلك
مرة أخرى حسنًا.  من المؤكد أن أصولنا الاستخبارية
مشغولة حقًا بمحاولة
تحديد كيفية حدوث ذلك، ومن
الممكن أن يكون قد حدث محض
صدفة، لكن من
وجهة نظري على الأرجح أنه في الواقع أه كان
متعمدًا، فهم يعرفون نمط طيران الطائرة بدون طيار
فوق سوريا، ولديهم رادار،
ولديهم وسائل أخرى  لمعرفة ما هي
أنماط الطيران هذه واكتشف شخص ما،
دعنا نسير خلف طائرتنا بدون طيار وسوف ندخل وقد جربوها وقد
نجحت، لذا من الواضح أن
الولايات المتحدة
ستغير إجراءاتها من الآن فصاعدًا ولكن
الأمر  من المحتمل أن هذا لم يكن
عرضيًا، وفي قلب كل
هذا هي حرب إسرائيل مع حماس، مما يجعل
الجهود الحالية للتفاوض على وقف
مؤقت لإطلاق النار مقابل
إطلاق سراح الرهائن، والأهم من ذلك هو
كيف يمكن تسريع هذه الجهود
للمساعدة ربما في تهدئة هذا الوضع
في الشرق
الأوسط، حسنًا، لقد استخدمت إيران هذا بالفعل
وربما دبرت جزئيًا هذا الهجوم الذي شنته
حماس على إسرائيل، وكل ذلك جزء من
خطة حملة إيرانية أكبر لطرد
الولايات المتحدة من المنطقة
حتى يمكن تركيز جميع الأصول الإيرانية.
حصريًا على إسرائيل وفي هذه
العملية يتم تعطيل
المبادرات الدبلوماسية الإقليمية الأخرى في
الولايات المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية
لذلك أه علينا أن ندرك أن هناك
خطة وراء كل هذا الآن إذا
تمكنا من التوصل إلى وقف إطلاق نار معقول أه
مؤقتًا في غزة وقبض على الرهائن
تم إطلاق سراحه، سيكون هذا أمرًا جيدًا حقًا
ولكن بالنسبة لإسرائيل، هذا الوضع في حماس
هو أنك لا تستطيع التعايش معه، ويجب عليك
إخراج حماس من غزة
لأن هذا يمثل تهديدًا
لوجود إسرائيل ونفس الشيء
الأمر صحيح مع الحسبة المدعومة من إيران
في جنوب لبنان، لذلك سيكون من الرائع
إطلاق سراح الرهائن وتخفيف
الضغط إذا حصلت على ستة، يتم
الحديث عن وقف إطلاق النار، لكن هذا
سيستمر لأن إسرائيل
ترى الآن  أكتب على الحائط أه
التهديد من إيران يقترب
ويجب التعامل معه مع الجنرال
ويسلي كلارك نحن نقدر
تحليلك العسكري شكرا جزيلا لانضمامك إلينا
شكرا لك